You might remember or you might not because
corporate media basically hasn't covered this,
which is that Donald Trump has been accused
not just as sexually assaulting more than
a dozen adult women, but of raping a 13 year
old girl.
And I've told you before that this, uh, event
allegedly took place along with one of Donald
Trump's. I don't know if we call them an associate
or an acquaintance or a friend, but it's a
guy named Jeffrey Epstein, a woman known only
as Jane Doe previously had alleged that when
she was 13 years old, Donald Trump raped her
at a party thrown by Jeffrey Epstein, and
that Epstein himself had also raped her. Now
the woman ended up fearing for her life and
dropping a civil suit against Donald Trump.
But of course the allegations themselves have
not been recanted. Epstein has been sort of
a slippery guy to actually charge a of a with
some of these, um, incidents. But he has now
been arrested and charged with sex trafficking,
dating back to the early two thousands he
is now facing charges for paying underage
girls for massages and molesting them in Florida
and New York homes that he owns.
And before we even get to the Trump connection,
because that's a whole other thing I have
to tell you, that the right is spreading endless
lies already about Epstein. One example is
the rightest saying the Robert Mueller FBI
allowed Epstein to plead to lesser charges
and avoid a long jail sentence. The truth
is that the deal Epstein previously got for
charges was from the then Miami u s attorney
Alexander Acosta, who happens to be Trump's
labor secretary. Now this is now really bad.
The records say Epstein brought 40 girls who
were underage to his Florida mansion and they
were sold into sexual encounters of all kinds.
These allegations are truly disgusting and
disturbing, and then the Trump piece pops
up. Trump said about Jeffrey Epstein to New
York magazine in 2002 quote, I've known Jeff
for 15 years. Terrific guy. He's a lot of
fun to be with. It is even said that he likes
beautiful women as much as I do and many of
them are on the younger side.
Not good, not good. So back to the allegations
that Donald Trump raped one of the same girls
that Epstein allegedly raped when she was
13 at Epstein's Manhattan Condo. I don't know
if they're going to resurface here as a result
of this arrest, but this is certainly not
what Donald Trump would consider to be good
news to have Jeffrey Epstein, the back in
the public spotlight in this way. Now I've
looked at the content of the lawsuit that
again was filed against Donald Trump for the
rape. The charges were eventually dropped
supposedly because of death threats against
the accuser. It is shocking what is in the
the the lawsuit. I'm not going to read it
to you. It's dozens of pages, but you can
easily find it online and we're going to link
to it on Youtube. The accuser claimed before
the lawsuit with was withdrawn just as a few
highlights that Trump threatened her to never
talk about the rape or she risked being hurt
or killed, which is exactly in line with the
intimidatory tactics that we know Donald Trump
has employed against such former mistresses
as stormy Daniels.
So it's all truly sick. I mean it really makes
me sick and much like with much of what's
going on with Donald Trump, there may never
be consequences, but with Epstein back in
the news, we will see and consider the number
of conflicts that are involved here. Donald
Trump is or was friends with Jeffrey Epstein.
The old prosecutor from Miami is now Trump's
labor secretary. Attorney General. William
Barr has recused himself from the entire Jeffrey
Epstein case because his former law firm once
represented Epstein. This is another reminder
of the incestuous nature of power, influence
and wealth in this country and Donald Trump
knows that this is not good for him and he
actually is on tilt. Next, I want to talk
about what he did at a rally to someone who
held up a picture of him with Jeffrey Epstein.